We can think of concepts lying on a spectrum.
On one extreme end are extremely formal concepts for
which we can define logical conditions that are necessary and
sufficient for that concept. We'll examine that in more detail in just a minute.
On the other end of the spectrum are less formal concepts for which it's hard to
define necessary and sufficient conditions. Now here are three points on
the spectrum. Axiomatic concepts, prototype concepts, exemplar concepts.
There can be other types of concepts as well. We're just going to
consider these three concepts because they are the three most common ones.
And we'll look at each one of them in turn. In general, humans find it
easier to communicate about axiomatic concepts because they are well defined.
There is a set of necessary and sufficient conditions that we all agree with.
Examples are mathematical concepts. Humans find it harder to communicate about
prototype concepts, but most of the time we do quite well. It's even harder to
talk about exemplar concepts like, let's say, beauty or freedom. Similarly,
it's easier to teach computers axiomatic concepts or program axiomatic concepts
into computers. It's much harder to program or teach prototype concepts.
And much, much harder to teach a program exemplar type concepts.